we're back now with our special series
school matters which looks at how to
safely reopen schools during the
pandemic and you've got to think about
transportation in a normal year about 26
million children
take a school bus so now schools are
scrambling to create plans to bring kids
to and from class
safely despite the virus but options for
social distancing on buses are limited
and there was already a shortage of
drivers before the pandemic
chris van cleave takes us on board a
school bus now in virginia
okay cj come on up sweet girl the first
day of school we gotta keep our masks on
okay
brought some big changes to gracie
duncan's school bus
okay james it's a little different this
year so what i'm going to get you to do
is go
all the way to the back the rocking r
with the a
okay the handful of students who climb
to board must wear masks
and go to assigned distant seats marked
with the school's logo filling the bus
from back to front here in radford
virginia the biggest difference students
will notice the bus capacity capped at
one third and they're going to be
staggered
to promote distancing duncan's bus seats
up to 64
but this year we'll have no more than 20
and the windows will be down to increase
ventilation but freshman brandon
thompson
was a little skeptical nervous because i
don't know if
the cases are going up in radford so you
don't know if you're going to get it or
you're not going to get it
and a survey of district parents found
only about 25 percent
say they'd let their kids take the bus
this year i've been in education this is
my 30th year
this is absolutely the hardest thing
that we've had to do by far
with the unknown and the amount of
changes that come
it's just been very very difficult to
make a plan and actually stay with it
rob graham is the radford superintendent
why not
cancel bus service why not just go
virtual and
and not introduce this risk there is a
risk and we've tried to make it as low
as possible
face to face but i think there's even a
bigger risk of not having our children
in school
face to face radford schools followed
cdc recommendations suggesting facial
coverings
driving with the windows open at least
once a day cleaning to disinfect buses
and creating distance between students
including seating children
at least one student per row facing
forward and skipping rows between
students have students distanced based
maybe every other seat
make sure that everyone's wearing a mask
and to discourage talking on the school
bus
and to make sure the windows are open as
much as possible
but in georgia where covet cases have
soared commerce city superintendent joy
tolbert
says some of those cdc recommendations
just aren't practical
we do not have students situated so
they're sitting
every other seat we do have students in
every seat on the bus
but we do have the windows down on the
bus to provide
additional ventilation 15 percent of the
city's 1800 students
opted for at home virtual learning but
social distancing options remain limited
and the district can't use its extra
buses because it lacks additional
drivers
there is a shortage of bus drivers and
that was
even the case before the corona virus
because
you just cannot find bus drivers while
fewer students
are riding don hensley still drives
dozens daily
everyone wears a mask i'm not anxious at
all i think kids do better in person
i personally think that everybody does
better with socialization
both districts have overhauled how they
clean using electrostatic foggers the
buses are disinfected daily
and between trips the drivers clean
again making sure to wipe down all touch
surfaces
it made me realize why haven't we always
done this during flu season
so i do see this as being the new normal
neither department had any drivers
opt out in radford gracie duncan says
she's happy to be back behind the wheel
were you nervous at all about being in
an enclosed space with a bunch of kids
i'm really not i know the safety
precautions we have in place i'll be
wearing my mask the kids will be wearing
theirs we're washing hands we're
sanitizing i'm feeling really optimistic
about getting back to it and being able
to do this and keep these kids safe
and keep the wheels on her bus headed
for class
for cbs this morning chris van cleave
radford virginia
no easy choices there bravo to both
districts for working
as best they can all right chris thank
you very much